I was at a party one night
and um
I was
drinking and people was taking drugs and
there was some burglaries that happened
that night and someone had had some car
keys from
they're coming out the back of the party
and it waved the car keys around and I'd
stupidly said I'd take these car keys
and I'd go and fill up the car with more
drink and get more drugs
[Music]
when you were growing up what was life
like
I was born and probably not into the
most stable of circumstances so
um
there was a lot of drink a lot of uh
drugs a lot of violence in and out
foster care quite a lot actually in the
younger years as well due to uh
neglect and abuse didn't really get much
time to be a kid my mum had bad epilepsy
as well so
she'd always be having epileptic fits
and they'll be trying to save her
so
with all the chaos and the drink and the
drugs and
it was difficult like to
there was times where I was on the
estate like cancel Estates with my mates
and we'd be having fun and it was like
getting into mischief and that and
towards year seven I'd kind of
just went off the rails a bit really
some of my mates would bring in cannabis
so it was hashing them like bringing
some hash and I thought wow so we
started smoking around the back of
school and I thought I was like the man
and uh
I didn't really have that much interest
in school after that I was
I wanted to creep into the offices next
door to the school and
steal stuff some of my makes it earlier
so I was mad because I used to walk into
places and just walk out with stuff
like I'd walk out of big massive high
fives
and man said he needs a speaker one time
so he took me down to the shop and he
waited outside he said this is the
speaker that I need
so I said yeah no problem and I went in
I flew and I got to speak and I just
walked straight out the door and give
him the speakers a massive blood I
didn't know what it was I was only like
11 12.
and I'll give him the speaker give me 40
quid and that was I was on a roll after
that
eventually the older boys that I was
hanging around with they kind of went
their separate ways and uh they didn't
really come around to my house no more
but it was a bail Hostel at the end of
the road where we'd got involved I'd got
involved with some
some people that have just been released
from prison it was a bell hostel and
some of them was on crack and
got talking to one of them and it went
on a few robberies with him and I'd got
the money and he kind of took the money
off me and went to buy a crack with it
and kind of introduced me to crack at an
early age
thing spiraled out of control from them
and my house become a crack house
so fast like just
it just happened so fast I lost all my
mates around the area
no one didn't really want to talk to me
no more
I was skinny I was withdrawn my face was
yellow I'd become a crack addict at 12.
might have robberies and burglaries are
cutting a lot more
ended up my mum was taking drugs and
other people in the house was taking
drugs and
and I'd seen some extreme violence at
that age
um
people overdosing on my floor and dying
people slapping them trying to get them
back round after they're taking a bad
hit of heroin or whatever it was and
uh in turn I getting in trouble on the
streets a lot and robbing a lot you in
turn get in trouble with the police a
lot so if everyone knows what you're
doing and knows
what you're up to eventually the police
know what you're up to and what you're
doing and I started getting arrested
quite a lot
I end up getting an anti-social
behavioral at 15.
and banned from my Borough
and I got sent to a children's home in
Croydon
I remember there was a Larder and it was
full of food
and uh
there was boys my age and
as I was getting there there was one boy
leaving the children's home where he
just left and they got onto the back of
the bus
and he had a little phone and a bag of
weed and uh
I just clicked with that guy straight
away man
his name was rifa and my name was Rocco
he just become my best friend
and he had a difficult upbringing the
same as me so we kind of related a lot
that we do stuff like on
we go to we went to a party one time and
he dressed all in white I just all in
black
and uh
there was loads and loads and loads of
things that we've done together
from all of that
what was the event that really changed
your life
I was at a party one night
and um
I was
drinking and people was taking drugs and
it just all went pretty bad
so you and your best friend were at the
same at that party
yes what happened there
there was like a lot of people taking
drugs and loud music and girls and
there was some burglaries that happened
that night and someone had some car keys
from
they're coming out the back of the party
and it waved the car keys around and
it said um does anybody want to take
these car keys and go and get more drugs
and go and get my drink from South
because we was at North at this stage so
um
stupidly I was still in the
process of making bad decisions or
the wrong choices in my life and
I'd stupidly said I'll take these car
keys and I'd go and fill up the car with
my drink and get more drugs
rifa was with me that night and another
guy called Lee
who my partner at the time it was her
mum's
partner or friend
I don't really
I don't remember
but
I try and imagine it if that makes sense
put the photos that I've seen
and
with the witness statements that I read
they done some blood samples from the
car and I was
over the drink Drive limit and the
cocaine that we was taking that was
taken was actually there was a lot of
ketamine in there
and um
I I didn't know that I was taking
ketamine and
I was drinking and
was on a mad one and
I remember laughing and joking with
reefer before and
it was cars that was alongside those or
and
we've been having an allocation with
some other boys in a car previous to
enter in a Blackwell tunnel because I'd
lost control coming out of the blackwall
tunnel
and it hit the lamp post at high speeds
into the driver's door where I was
sitting
and
to Lamppost
and through the cons
my best friend died
and leaves in the back lost his leg
the next thing I just remember waking up
in hospital
and uh
honestly asked just the worst I am
really really hard and it still does
how old were you at that point
I was 18.
um I was 18 when the crash happened
how old was your best friend
it was 19.
he was older than me so he was like my
older like so
I would like listen to him
and he was proper loyal
one of the most little friends I ever
have in my life without a shadow of a
doubt
and he loved me and he told me they
loved me and I loved him as well and he
always used to talk about me and I
always used to talk about him wherever
you see rifa Rocco was not far behind
him where he actually rock or Reef was
not far behind but
um sorry can I have a minute I'm trying
so hard to just hold these tears back
I'm sorry of course do you need a tissue
no thanks
thanks
it hit me when I when I
when I went to Siri Farm
with his family and
and I cuddled him
and my tears dropped all over his face
it's like the world Carries On
and you want it all to stop
because it's not really fair that
he's not here no more
and uh
I get to live the rest of my life and
he doesn't get to see his daughter and
and that's ultimately my fault
what was your sentence
I was given a five-year
in five years I was given five years in
prison and a five-year driving ban
but that's not really my sentence that
my sentence is what I go to sleep with
and what I wake up with
what was time in prison like
prison was like I tried to keep myself
to myself and get on with my sentence
and get out
for my children so
there was the most difficult part in
prison was when they shut the door and I
knew why I was there
and I was alone with my thoughts and my
heart
and just missing reefer really that was
like the hardest part of prison
knowing that
I ain't gonna never see him again
and that made me mad all the way through
my prison sentence so I was
proper angular
I'm still very good by now really
why did you get clean
oh after the crashing after prison I
never really took any more drugs or
drink I don't drink I don't take any
drugs now I've been working in the
education system for the last 10 years
I've shared my story with tens and tens
of thousands of youngsters
to try and help them make the better
choices in life and de-glamorize prison
and makes them know that that their
choices are going to have a massive
effect on the rest of their lives and
and I kind of thought that my younger
years was bad in it it's not it's not
just me there's hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of kids
that have worse stories than me tap tap
that a lot worse stuff happened to you
when they was kids so
those people want to say carry on
and keep going
because
things are definitely get better
and they were really really good people
in the world that can help
I want to say this all without this
emotion
I just wanna
if you could give one advice to to your
younger self what would that be
think about your choices wisely kid
if you can see anyone getting into a bad
situation and you can stop it then
do the right thing
I guess one last thing I wanted to ask
is
how are you now
I still struggle with mental health now
it's been nearly 15 years
and it doesn't matter whether I get to
the end of my life I don't think it's
going to hurt any less
as much as the lover of his family I'll
still feel that
I can get so low and
not want to be alive no more
but oh it's a refit to try and bring
some positive artists and do something
with my life and I I don't want his
death to be in vain I want to try and do
I want him to be remembered and want to
do good I want to bring light from this
dark situation so my story can help
someone
that's why I'm here
[Music]
my favorite punch at the guy that my
mate was arguing with and um
and he fell on the floor
my friends came around the next day
yes Jacob you know your punch man
knocked him out one punch like trying to
like
praise me